Haiti is known for its fantastic cuisine
so while I'm here
what if I learn how to make Haitian food
and perfect place to do it is a place
called world central kitchen I thought
maybe I could learn to make Haitian food
and in return maybe I would teach them
how to toast a pop-tart or just eat it
raw is am I saying it well miss initial
Shivani could you were the chief you run
world central kitchen is that right yes
Bonjour say that's very nice I love the
way you say it it's like a von Trapp
first you often you learn how to avoid
your knife hold my knife watching her
doing what that's a sliced onion what's
wrong with that
can we just pretend that it was okay yes
this is marijuana
Dean Oh time time time okay okay okay
we're gonna make a filet of red snapper
what is this this is this is shrimp yes
and just rip go in here anywhere no yeah
we made another
I cut out we could add we could make a
whole new house yes yes right I'm gonna
combine both of you and make a Haitian
dish it's never been made before this
guy's amazing sure glad we met him
there's just one problem you both have
to die that's all right onion onion
mm-hmm just sprinkle it as much as you
want
ah look everybody nice huh
he's not clapping
why didn't eat that you'll see I'll get
you what's his name miss yeah Lucien
Lucien will learn to respect me ah my
invention Luciana you didn't think of
that did you know how we wait ready
thank you for cooking with us oh yes
[Applause]
the world central kitchen school relies
entirely on charitable contributions to
donate please go to world central
kitchen org
you